foreign
there's a story of mine that I've told
about a million different times and it
goes a little something like this
when I was 10 my family and I packed up
our entire lives into large suitcases
and dragged them across the Pacific to a
foreign land called Canada
I was put in a school where I was the
only Asian kid in my grade
and I got teased for my broken English
Asian features and funny smelling ethnic
lunches
the racism was a real doozy but don't
feel bad through the magical healing
powers of extracurricular activities and
pure perseverance I stand before you
today a new woman
healthy healed and extremely employable
you wouldn't even be able to tell from
just looking at me that I was once the
weird little immigrant girl who begged
her mom to pack PB J sandwiches so she
wouldn't have to eat lunch alone in the
bathroom
this is a story that I've told in
academic essays job interviews and even
in the very application that got me into
this fine University
it's also a story that despite all of
its truth I've come to hate
now this is a story that I don't have
copyright claim over it's one that
continues to be regurgitated by
immigrant kids all across the country to
be served on a silver platter to
prestigious universities who true these
stories and spit out acceptance letters
in return the contents of the story may
change instead of a difficult
immigration experience it might be the
death of a loved one a chronic illness
or a racist encounter but what remains
constant is the moral
a bad thing happened to me but it made
me a good person
this is part of the larger phenomenon
that I'm here to talk about today
the overwhelming pressure being put on
high school students to write about
their deepest traumas in their college
applications with the hopes that they
seem resilient and interesting enough to
be given a spot
I believe that these are not only bad
metrics by which to evaluate applicants
but also incredibly harmful to the
Storyteller themselves and risks
reinforcing existing inequities in
higher education there's also pressure
that's being Amplified by admissions
counselors themselves who play a huge
role in influencing what applicants
decide to write about
take for example this tip from the MIT
admissions blog where the author
Compares two different introductions for
a potential essay the first one reads
I'm honored to apply for the master of
Library science program at the
University of Okoboji for as long as I
can remember I've had a love affair with
books since I was 11 I've wanted to be a
librarian
the second introduction reads when I was
11 my great-aunt Gretchen passed away
and left me something that changed my
life a library of about 5 000 books some
of my best days were spent arranging and
reading her books since then I've wanted
to become a librarian
the author notes that the second
introduction is much more striking and
leaves a much better impression
consider another tip from college
scguy.com where he advises students to
get personal
he says weirdly including including
painful memories and what you learned
from them usually helps a personal
statement meet the goals of a college
application essay you come off as humble
accessible likable and mature
confessions from admissions officers
themselves can also be telling
Aya Waller Bay a former admissions
officer from Georgetown University said
in a forms article that within months on
the job I saw how the personal
statements of black and other racially
minority students deferred from those of
white applicants
black students highlighted resilience
through stories of survival while their
counterparts wrote casual essays about
service abroad and sporting
championships
black students shared their pain white
students shared their passions
now lastly and perhaps the least
reliable source is my own life
I remember feeling this way when I was
applying to universities
like I had no other choice no other
experiences worthy of mentioning and no
other Merit beyond the fact that I had
thrived despite what I had gone through
I even remember worrying that my tail
wouldn't be harrowing enough after
hearing from a counselor that writing
about immigration has become a bit of a
cliche because of how overused it is
so what's the University's role in all
of this and why are these stories even
harmful to begin with
well I believe that using your college
application essay to discuss your trauma
actually doesn't help you process it
there are a couple different reasons why
first writing about a difficult
experience is as you may have guessed
difficult
not only do you have to relive the event
itself but you also have to actively
suppress any negative emotions that
arise during the process
that kind of emotional labor can be
taxing for anybody but perhaps
especially so for these young applicants
who haven't had enough time on this
world to process the terrible things
that have happened to them for that
space to be one in which they're
confessing to a faceless stranger who
gets to make the most consequential
decision of their adolescent life
imposes an incredibly heavy
psychological burden I mean imagine if
you walked into your therapy appointment
and your therapist tells you that
they're not going to respond to anything
you tell them except with a rejection or
acceptance email sent months later and
also that whatever you tell them would
determine the trajectory of your entire
academic and professional career
hard to imagine that being therapeutic
secondly the trauma essay makes one
assumption that is extremely problematic
it's not always the learning opportunity
through which you can gain more
confidence or develop better time
management skills
sometimes it's just a sucky thing that
really sucks
and asking students to prove how they
turn their pain into progress ignores
this truth and false prey to the toxic
positivity narrative that everything
happens for a reason ignoring the very
valid resentment and anger that many
victims still feel
lastly the things we write aren't just
informed by your experiences they shape
how we view those experiences as well
and if we're writing about our trauma to
prove to our admissions officer that we
are worthy of a decent education then it
becomes necessary to sanitize our pain
to make it marketable and strategic
to scrub away all the suffering so all
that's left is what will fit into the
narrow margins of what is palatable
and this is what I see as being the
fundamental contradiction at the heart
of the trauma essay
it seems to give the writer free reign
of vulnerability but actually leaves
them very little room to be vulnerable
your story has to be just sad enough
that it gains sympathy but not so sad
that it makes you seem beyond help
just critical enough to inspire change
but not so much that it actually
criticizes systemic structures
just honest enough to seem real but not
so unfiltered that it creates discomfort
the protagonist also overcomes whatever
struggle they're facing by the end of
the 500 word count instilling the reader
with a sense of optimism that despite
our deeply unequal Society it is
possible to rise through the ranks and
overcome all the isms this of course is
not the reality of our world today
and for me this looked like settling for
the familiar story of the stinky lunge
one that's been told so many times that
it's devoid of any real meaning instead
of talking about the ongoing social and
political disenfranchisement of
immigrants the permanent loss of
cultural identity that I suffered or the
sense of disbelonging that still haunts
me every time I make a grammar mistake
or someone mispronounces my name
these are all struggles that never
really go away but are carefully tucked
away in my essay because they don't fit
the linear narrative that is being
constructed
but how are universities to blame for
all of this I mean they never explicitly
asked students to trauma dump in their
essays and many admissions experts have
actually come out and discouraged
discussing explicit trauma in essays
however I still don't think that
universities are blameless
the reason why the trauma essay is so
ubiquitous is because it seems to be
working
and Trebek who helped low-income high
school students at Oberlin College write
their essays expresses the ethical
dilemma that she faces
by pushing students to reveal their
horror stories I risk taking away their
dignity but by not pushing I could be
hindering their chances of getting into
their dream School
whether trauma essays and acceptance
letters are actually causally correlated
or impot is impossible to tell from the
outside so this could all just be
speculation and myth but in failing to
resolutely clear up the speculation and
myths about whether trauma essays are
rewarded or discouraged universities are
indirectly enabling the rise of the
trauma essay and all of its harmful
implications
so what are they to do about all of this
well first of all I think that this is a
problem that goes much deeper than
individual universities and even perhaps
the institution of higher education
itself
it's rooted in the cultural obsession
with appropriating trauma and making it
consumable as well as the systemic
tendency to tokenize oppressed people
and their experiences
but there are still things that
universities can do to make things
better
first they can be more transparent about
their admissions guidelines
if it's really true that they don't want
to reward trauma storytelling just for
the sake of it then they should be more
forthcoming about this expectation
they could also restructure their
prompts to avoid putting pressure on
students to talk about past hardships
and adversities and instead refocus
prompts to ask students about their
goals for the future and their academic
interests
secondly admissions counselors should be
trauma informed and trained in working
with bipoc Folk as The Unofficial
Gatekeepers to the secrets of getting
into your dream College they should
wield their power responsibly and not
pressure students to talk about
traumatic experiences that they're not
yet ready to talk about
lastly and this one's for anyone who's
actually applying to a post-secondary
institution sometime soon remember that
you are more than the bad things that
happen to you
I know that when it seems like every
other classmate of yours is writing an
essay that could be adapted for an HBO
original drama that you may feel like
your experiences are not worth talking
about but I promise that they are you
just have to find your voice and use it
now as much as I don't want to live that
nail-bitingly stressful time of my life
ever again I can't help but Wonder
what would I have written about if I got
the chance to apply to UBC again this
time absent the pressure to
strategically use my immigrant
background to gain sympathy points
maybe I would have written about
how I overcame my fear of public
speaking and became comfortable with
being the loudest voice in the room
or I could have written about watching
trashy reality television is what first
sparked my interest in political science
or maybe I still would have written
about my immigrant story because that
was a big part of my life journey and
still impacts me to this day
but I would have done it on my own terms
instead of being written as a
one-dimensional trauma-turned Triumph
drama drama
I would have been able to tell a story
that actually reflects who I am today
and acknowledge the fact that my journey
is ongoing and it doesn't begin or end
with my racial identity
this is the kind of ownership that I
wish for everyone to one day have over
their story
and now it's up for universities to
decide whether they get to tell it
thank you